هذا زنسكي الذي استفاد من تفشي الفساد في
حملته الانتخابيه قبل اربعه اعوام يجد
نفسه الان متورطا في اكتوبر 2001
وهي تسريبات لوثائق حول ثروات مخيفه بشكل
غير مشروع وفقا للوثائق شركه في شبكه
المتراميه الاطراف من الشركات الخارجيه
تعود الى عام 2012 هذه الشركات ملكيتها
مشتركه مع اصدقائه القدامى الذين انتجوا
له مسلسله الشهير خادم الشعب في 2015 من
بين هؤلاء الاصدقاء سر هي الشرير كبير
مساعدتك في الرئاسه وابانوب سيلنسكي رئيس
جهاز الامن في اوكرانيا الذي اقيم فيه
يوليو الماضي احد هو التفاصيل المثيره في
الوثائق انه تم استخدامه الشركات من قبل
الشفير وشريك تجاري لشراء
شقه باهظه الثمن في لندن احدها يقع على
بعد مسافه قصيره من متحف في شارع بيبيكر
ستريت وهو عنوان المحقق الخيالي شارلوك
هولمز يبدو انه بالصدفه فضح شلقونز بعضا
من الفساد في اوكرانيا
تبوزيلانسكي رفض التعليق على هذه التهام
قبل ايام لكنه اصلا ولكن هذه الاتهامات
ليست الوحيده فهناك شبهات فساد تحيط
بالرئيس الاوكراني وتحدث عنها في حلقه
السابقه ما يخص معاملات تجاريه لهنترب
ايضا نجل الرئيس الامريكي
مشكلتي مع اوكرانيا رغم انني احب الرئيس
زينسكي وقد كانت كذلك قبل وصوله الى الحكم
هي اكثر البلدان فسادا في العالم تم
تصنيفهم من بين الاسود وانا لا اريد ان
اعطي المال لبلد بهذا المستوى من الفساد